From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是由美国公共广播国际公司发行的《美国生活》。
My [UNINTELLIGIBLE] sergeant put me on a deployment roster to go to the Middle East. And I was told to go to a pre-deployment brief.
我的军士长把我列入了前往中东的部署名单。我还被告知去参加一次部署前的简报会。
This guy's a Lance Corporal from the Marines' Eight Communication Battalion at Camp Lejeune, North Carolina. At his pre-deployment briefing to go overseas for whatever is going to happen next in Iraq, there were maybe 300 Marines.
这人是来自北卡罗来纳州勒琼营地海军陆战队第八通信营的一名下士。在他准备前往海外应对伊拉克后续事态的部署前简报会上，大约有300名海军陆战队员在场。
You know, folding chairs. There was a projection screen being used to show us the plan of attack.
你知道，就是折叠椅。当时用了一个投影屏幕向我们展示作战计划。
OK, this is where we're going to be landing. And then we're going to travel here. You'll be wearing this type of gear. They also taught us about Saddam Hussein's military. You know, how much he has. And after that, this other speaker came out speaking about the Arab culture. He was a sergeant and how the Marine Corps works per se, this guy is not specializing in Arab culture. You know, he was probably asked to do a course on Arab culture two weeks prior to the situation. He did some research, per se, and gave the class.
“好了，这就是我们将要登陆的地方。然后我们要前往这里。你们将穿着这种装备。”他们还向我们传授了关于萨达姆·侯赛因军队的知识。比如，他有多少兵力。在那之后，另一位演讲者走上台，讲起了阿拉伯文化。他是一名军士长，从海军陆战队的运作方式来说，这人并不是阿拉伯文化方面的专家。你知道，他很可能是在情况发生前两周才被要求开设一门关于阿拉伯文化的课程。他自己做了一些研究，就把课给讲了。
In the class, the sergeant explained what Arabs eat. That it gets to 140 degrees in the desert. The different ethnic groups.
在课堂上，那位军士长解释了阿拉伯人吃什么。沙漠里的气温会达到140华氏度。还有不同的民族群体。
Then he said to us, when you go over there, make sure you do not shake an Arab with your left hand. And we're all wondering, why? So he says and the reason is because over in Iraq, over in the Middle East, they wipe their asses with their left hand because they don't have any toilet paper. And so I'm standing there and I could see people's faces. And they were like in disgust. They're like, "Oh man. Wow. That's just nasty."
接着他对我们说：“当你们去到那边时，一定要确保不要用左手去和阿拉伯人握手。”我们都很纳闷，为什么？于是他说，原因是在伊拉克，在中东，他们用左手擦屁股，因为他们没有卫生纸。我当时就站在那里，我能看到人们脸上的表情。他们看起来很恶心，心想：“天哪。哇。那真是太脏了。”
This Marine told us that he thought the only reason the sergeant said that was to make the soldiers think that Arabs are disgusting, to make them hate. Who knows? Honestly, who knows? We checked into it and it's true. Lots of people in Iraq and Pakistan, and lots of other countries near there, do not use toilet paper. People wash their hands. But that sergeant really might have been trying to teach them how to be sensitive to local customs, just didn't do the very best job of it.
那位海军陆战队员告诉我们，他认为军士长之所以这么说，唯一的目的就是让士兵们觉得阿拉伯人很恶心，从而激起他们的仇恨。谁知道呢？老实说，谁知道呢？我们核实了一下，这是事实。在伊拉克、巴基斯坦以及附近许多其他国家的许多人，确实不使用卫生纸。人们会洗手。但那位军士长可能真的是想教他们如何尊重当地习俗，只是做得不够好而已。
Once there's a war going on, everyone is suspicious of the information they're getting. Nothing is trustworthy. And when a war is over, it's still hard to tell what the truth was. For instance, the number of Iraqi deaths in the Persian Gulf War back in 1991, do you know? No one knows. Just after the war, the US Defense Intelligence Agency made a very rough estimate of 100,000. The British government says 30,000. The US House Armed Services Committee estimated 9,000. The PBS show Frontline estimated maybe 27,000.
一旦战争爆发，每个人都会对他们获得的信息持怀疑态度。没有任何东西是可信的。而当战争结束后，依然很难辨别什么是真相。例如，1991年波斯湾战争中伊拉克人的死亡人数，你知道吗？没人知道。战争刚结束时，美国国防情报局给出了一个非常粗略的估计，即10万人。英国政府说3万人。美国众议院军事委员会估计为9000人。PBS的《前线》节目估计大约是2.7万人。
Well today on our program, we bring you three stories, each one from a different war. Each one trying to get you the real true story behind that war.
今天的节目，我们带来三个故事，每个故事都来自不同的战争。每个故事都试图让你了解战争背后的真实真相。
Act One of our show, Jarheads. In that act, a marine reminds us just how scary it was to fight against Saddam Hussein the last time around if you weren't just watching on TV.
本节目的第一幕，“海军陆战队员”。在这一幕中，一位海军陆战队员提醒我们，如果你不仅仅是在电视上看的话，与萨达姆·侯赛因作战是多么令人恐惧。
Act Two, what's the truth good for anyway. An act which asked the question, if Israelis looked back at their war of independence and decided that maybe they shared some blame for Palestinians having their country, would it change anything?
第二幕，“真相到底有什么用”。这一幕提出了一个问题：如果以色列人回顾他们的独立战争，并认为巴勒斯坦人失去家园，他们也许负有一定的责任，这会改变什么吗？
Act Three, Jar Jar Heads. In that act, one brave and funny man doesn't simply try to rewrite the history of a war, he tries to rewrite the movie of the history of the war. Stay with us.
第三幕，“加加头”。在这一幕中，一位勇敢而有趣的人并没有简单地尝试重写战争历史，他试图重写那部关于战争历史的电影。请继续收听。
Act One.
第一幕。
I'm Anthony Swofford and I served in the US Marine Corps from December of 1988 through December of 1992. And when I left the Marine Corps I was a corporal.
我是安东尼·斯沃福德，我从1988年12月到1992年12月在美国海军陆战队服役。当我离开海军陆战队时，我是一名下士。
And Anthony Swofford is here because he agreed to read an excerpt from his memoir, Jarhead: A Marine's Chronicle of the Gulf War and Other Battles.
安东尼·斯沃福德今天来到这里，是因为他同意朗读他回忆录中的片段，书名是《罐头人：一名海军陆战队员的海湾战争及其他战斗纪实》。
And Anthony, before we start, I want to do a quick rundown of some of the words that are going to appear here and there during the readings so nobody gets lost. Give me just quick definitions to these. Ruck.
安东尼，在开始之前，我想快速梳理一下在朗读过程中偶尔会出现的一些词汇，免得大家听不懂。请给我简单解释一下这些词。Ruck（背囊）。
Ruck is a pack, like a knapsack.
Ruck就是一种背包，就像行军背囊。
Dope.
Dope（情报）。
Well, dope is any sort of information that helps you at all in the field, such as the distance you are from a target, or the wind speed.
Dope是指在战场上对你有任何帮助的信息，比如你距离目标的距离，或者风速。
Or intelligence?
或者是情报？
Or any kind of intelligence, yes.
或者任何种类的情报，是的。
Freqs. That's F-R-E-Q-S.
Freqs（频率）。即F-R-E-Q-S。
Those are the radio frequencies that are being used on the battlefield.
那是战场上正在使用的无线电频率。
A grand.
A grand（一公里）。
A grand is one kilometer.
A grand就是一公里。
STA. That's S-T-A. It appears all through this story.
STA。即S-T-A。它贯穿整个故事。
STA is the acronym for the platoon I served in. It stands for Surveillance and Target Acquisition.
STA是我服役排的缩写。它代表“监视与目标获取”。
I hope this next one isn't too naive. Click. This is one that I feel like I've seen in a million war movies and they always say, go three clicks over, or five clicks over. And I've always wondered, how far is a click?
希望接下来这个词不会太幼稚。Click（公里）。我觉得在无数战争电影中都见过这个词，他们总是说，“再走三个click，或者五个click。”我一直很想知道，一个click到底有多远？
Yeah, a click is one kilometer. A thousand meters.
是的，一个click就是一公里。一千米。
Well, with that preparation, here then is Anthony Swofford, reading from his memoir of the Persian Gulf War.
有了这些准备，下面请听安东尼·斯沃福德朗读他关于波斯湾战争的回忆录。
The oven heat of the Arabian Desert grips my throat. In the distance, the wind blows sand from the tops of dunes, beige waves that billow through the mirage. Just beyond the tarmac, artillery batteries point their guns east and north. Fighter jets patrol the sky.
阿拉伯沙漠的烤箱热气紧紧扼住我的喉咙。远处，风吹起沙丘顶端的沙子，米色的波浪在海市蜃楼中翻滚。在柏油路面之外，炮兵连将枪口指向东方和北方。战斗机在天空中巡逻。
Our days consist of sand and water and sweat and piss. We look north toward what we're told is a menacing military, 400,000 or more of war torn and war savvy men. Some of the Iraqi soldiers who fought during the eight year war with Iran got their first taste of combat when we were 10 years old.
我们的日子由沙子、水、汗水和尿液组成。我们向北望去，那里据说是威胁我们的军队，有40万甚至更多的久经沙场、战争经验丰富的人。一些在与伊朗长达八年的战争中战斗过的伊拉克士兵，在我们10岁时就尝到了战斗的滋味。
While fighting Iran, the Iraqis became experts at fortifying their border with mines and obstacles, such as the 30 kilometer long lake they created to defend the city of Basra. We're forced to wonder what the Iraqis are preparing for us at the Saudi-Kuwaiti border.
在与伊朗作战时，伊拉克人成为了加固边界以防御地雷和障碍物的专家，例如他们为保卫巴士拉市而创造的30公里长的湖泊。我们不得不怀疑伊拉克人在沙特与科威特边界为我们准备了什么。
In 1983 and 1984, they use mustard and nerve gas against the Iranians. And since then, they've dropped nerve gas on the Iraqi Kurds. We believe they'll do the same to us. We wait for the Iraqi army. This is our labor, we wait.
在1983年和1984年，他们对伊朗人使用了芥子气和神经毒气。从那时起，他们又对伊拉克库尔德人投放了神经毒气。我们相信他们也会对我们这么做。我们等待着伊拉克军队。这就是我们的工作，我们等待。
Knowing the reporters will arrive soon, we shave for the first time in a week. Our chief scout sniper gathers the platoon in a school circle under the plastic infrared cover. He has already recited a list of unacceptable topics. He's ordered us to act like top Marines, patriots, the best of the battalion.
知道记者很快就会到达，我们一周来第一次刮了胡子。我们的首席侦察狙击手把全排召集在红外遮盖物下的圆圈里。他已经背诵了一份不可谈论的话题清单。他命令我们表现得像顶级海军陆战队员、爱国者，营里最棒的士兵。
We're prohibited from divulging to the press data concerning the capabilities of our sniper rifles or optics and the length and intensity of our training. Basically, don't get specific, he says. Say you can shoot from far away. Say you're highly trained. That there are no better shooters in the world than marine snipers. Say you're excited to be here and you believe we'll annihilate the Iraqis. Take off your shirts and show your muscles.
我们被禁止向媒体泄露有关狙击步枪或光学瞄准镜性能的数据，以及我们训练的长度和强度。基本上，他说，“别说具体的。就说你们可以从很远的地方射击。说你们训练有素。说世界上没有比海军陆战队狙击手更棒的射手。说你们很高兴来到这里，并相信我们会消灭伊拉克人。脱掉上衣，展示你们的肌肉。”
The reporters arrive at 09, 9 o'clock. The man is from the New York Times and the woman is from the Boston Globe. They shake our hands and urge us to speak freely.
记者们在9点钟到达。男人来自《纽约时报》，女人来自《波士顿环球报》。他们和我们握手，鼓励我们畅所欲言。
Yes ma'am, we believe in our mission, we say. We will quickly win this war and send the enemy crawling home. We can shoot out someone's eyeball from a click away.
“是的，长官，我们相信我们的使命，”我们说，“我们将迅速赢得这场战争，并让敌人爬着回家。我们可以从一公里外射中某人的眼球。”
One reporter has brought a football. On seeing it, the press pool colonel instructs our staff sergeant that we should play football for the reporters, wearing our full MOPP gear with gas masks. The MOPP suit is supposed to protect us from skin contamination during a chemical attack. They weigh 10 pounds and after 6 weeks in our rucks, most of them aren't in their original packaging, but are bound together with duct tape and nylon ripcord. We're happy to use them for this game because now they'll really be useless. We'll burn them in the straddle trench and it will take supply months to issue replacements.
一位记者带来了一个橄榄球。看到橄榄球后，媒体主管上校指示我们的上士，让我们穿着全套防化装备（MOPP gear）和防毒面具为记者们表演打橄榄球。防化服旨在保护我们免受化学攻击时的皮肤污染。它们重达10磅，在背囊里塞了6周后，大多数包装都烂了，只能用胶带和尼龙拉绳捆在一起。我们很高兴把它们拿来玩这个游戏，因为反正它们也没用了。我们会在战壕里烧掉它们，后勤补给部门要花几个月时间才能发新的给我们。
Doc John Duncan, our navy corpsman, reports the temperatures has reached 112 degrees. We pull our masks on and tie the hoods. Five gallon water jugs mark the goals. My team makes 10 yards. [? Coumbes ?] and Johnny Rotten get into a pushing match, and a few of us pull them apart. The drama of the scene is catching. The reporters are taking notes.
我们的海军医护兵约翰·邓肯医生报告说温度已经达到了112华氏度。我们戴上防毒面具，系好头罩。五加仑的水壶成了球门。我所在的队伍推进了10码。[库姆布斯]和约翰尼·罗滕发生了推搡，我们几个人把他们拉开。这场戏的戏剧性很有感染力。记者们正在做记录。
The gas mask and hood cause your hearing to lengthen and stretch, so that words enter your brain in slow motion. At some point, I hear the staff sergeant calling for halftime, telling the reporters that our gas masks are high tech pieces of equipment. That outfitted in the MOPP suits, we are an unstoppable fighting force. That the only chance the Iraqis have is to drop an a-bomb on us.
防毒面具和头罩让你的听觉变得迟钝和拉长，以至于话语以慢动作进入大脑。在某个时刻，我听到上士呼喊中场休息，告诉记者们我们的防毒面具是高科技装备。穿着防化服，我们是一支不可阻挡的战斗部队。伊拉克人唯一的生存机会就是向我们投掷原子弹。
When the show game is over, [? Keen ?] douses the suits with fuel and strikes a match. He says, may God please save us because these MOPP suits won't.
当这场表演游戏结束后，[基恩]把燃料倒在防化服上，划着了火柴。他说，愿上帝拯救我们，因为这些防化服救不了我们。
One night on the headquarters roof, Johnny notices that we can see straight into the general's office. And that if we use binoculars, we can read his wall map. Every symbol that reflects troop strength and movement, both enemy and friendly. And so we construct our own model of what will occur at the border.
一天晚上在总部屋顶，约翰尼注意到我们可以直接看到将军的办公室。如果我们使用望远镜，我们甚至可以读出墙上的地图。每一个代表部队兵力和动向的符号，无论是敌军还是友军。于是，我们构建了自己的模型，推测在边境会发生什么。
After three nights of transcribing the general's maps, we're sure that we'll soon be dead. Johnny does the math and he has us out-manned at the infantry level three to one.
在誊抄了三个晚上的将军地图后，我们确信自己很快就会死掉。约翰尼算了算，他在步兵层面以三比一的比例压制了我们。
The war begins. Within hours of the first US bombs being dropped on Iraqi forces in Kuwait and Iraq, the Iraqi air force threat is demolished. On the eighth of February, we move to the berm, the obstacle made of sand, an unstable material that will make futile all endeavour. That follows roughly the Kuwaiti-Saudi border.
战争开始了。在第一批美国炸弹投向伊拉克在科威特和伊拉克的部队数小时内，伊拉克空军的威胁就被摧毁了。2月8日，我们移动到了防波堤，那是一个由沙子构成的障碍物，是一种不稳定的材料，会让所有的努力都变得徒劳。它大致沿着科威特和沙特的边界延伸。
Shortly after arriving at the bivouac site, we receive incoming artillery rounds. Johnny is the first to yell, "Incoming." And we crouch in our half-dug hole.
在到达宿营地后不久，我们就遭到了炮火轰击。约翰尼是第一个大喊“有炮弹”的人，我们蜷缩在半挖好的坑里。
The rounds explode beautifully and the desert opens like a flower of sand. As the rounds hit, they make a sound of exhalation, as though air is being forced out of the earth. Sand rains into our hole.
炮弹在美丽的爆炸中绽放，沙漠像一朵沙子之花一样裂开。当炮弹落下时，它们发出一种呼气的声音，仿佛空气正被从大地中强行挤出。沙子雨点般落入我们的坑中。
More rounds land nearby and someone yells, "Gas. Gas. Gas." We don and clear our gas masks. More rounds hit and these explosions too, look beautiful and beat the earth, seeming to force air out of it. And I cry inside my mask because I'm finally in combat.
更多炮弹落在附近，有人大喊：“毒气！毒气！毒气！”我们穿戴并清理了防毒面具。更多的炮弹击中，这些爆炸看起来也很美丽，击打着大地，似乎要将空气从里面挤出来。我在面具里哭泣，因为我终于进入了战斗。
I piss my pants. My heart rate climbs. My breathing becomes shallow in the mask. I can't hear very well. Johnny and I look at each other and around our defensive position. More shells explode near us.
我尿裤子了。我的心跳加速。在面具里我的呼吸变得急促。我听不太清楚。约翰尼和我看着对方，环顾我们的防御阵地。更多炮弹在我们附近爆炸。
If the Iraqis have competent forward observers, they will adjust their fire 100 feet north and land rounds directly on the commanding officer and executive officer of the Second Battalion Seventh and Marines. But this is unlikely. They aren't competent. The assault ends.
如果伊拉克人有称职的前线观察员，他们会调整火力，向北移动100英尺，直接把炮弹落在海军陆战队第二营第七团的指挥官和执行官身上。但这不太可能。他们并不称职。袭击结束了。
We begin to look for an enemy observation post and the bastards who called in the rounds toward our command post. We scoured the biblical range 2,000 yards to our east, our bellies flat to the sand. Johnny is first to notice the enemy position. With his direction, I also make out the physical structure of the observation post dug into the side of the range like a wound into the ribs of a martyr. Those sons of bitches.
我们开始寻找敌方观察哨以及那些引导炮弹轰击我们指挥所的混蛋。我们趴在沙地上，搜寻着2000码外如圣经般广阔的区域。约翰尼首先发现了敌方阵地。在他的指引下，我也辨认出了那个观察哨的物理结构，它像一个烈士肋骨上的伤口一样挖掘在山脊一侧。那些狗娘养的。
Johnny dials the air freqs and I work the coordinates. We accomplish our map work like the experts we are, while all around us marines yell that they're OK, that they haven't been hit, and let's drop some [BLEEP] on those rag head mother [BLEEP].
约翰尼拨通了空中频率，我计算了坐标。我们像专家一样完成了地图工作，而周围所有的海军陆战队员都在大喊他们没事，他们没被击中，让我们把那些爆炸投到那些“裹头巾的混蛋”身上。
Johnny asks and I tell him that I think the best bomb cocktail would be a combination of smoke for obscuration and marking, and anti-bunker for killing. He gives me the handset and says, [BLEEP] them up, Swoff.
约翰尼询问，我告诉他，我认为最好的炸弹组合是用于遮蔽和标记的烟雾弹，以及用于杀伤的防掩体炸弹。他把手柄递给我说：“炸烂他们，斯沃福。”
A captain from S3 appears and pulls rank, insisting that he direct the fire mission. Not me, not STA, even though Johnny has located the enemy position, and I have acquired the coordinates. The captain has even carried a field chair over. He explains that he has bad knees from college football and that if he lies prone in the sand it will take about three STA Marines to peel him from the deck.
来自S3的一名上尉出现并以军衔压人，坚持由他来指挥这次火力任务。不是我，也不是STA（监视与目标获取小队），尽管是约翰尼定位了敌方阵地，而我获得了坐标。这位上尉甚至带了一把野战椅。他解释说他在大学踢橄榄球时膝盖受了伤，如果他趴在沙地上，得要三个STA海军陆战队员才能把他从地上拽起来。
Johnny takes the handset from me and gives it to the captain. And we crawl backward a few feet and listen to the captain call in the planes. A minute later, I watched the devastation through my spotter scope. I saw thousands of bombs land on targets while I was in training, buildings constructed for the purpose of being bombed turning to dust, and the hulks of decommissioned vehicles becoming twisted piles of steel. But I've never witnessed the extermination of human life.
约翰尼从我手中接过手柄，交给了上尉。我们向后爬了几英尺，听着上尉呼叫飞机。一分钟后，我通过我的观察镜目睹了这场毁灭。我在训练时看到过成千上万枚炸弹落在目标上，为了被轰炸而建造的建筑物化为尘土，退役车辆的残骸变成扭曲的钢堆。但我从未亲眼目睹生命的终结。
Through my scope the explosions look about the same size as the artillery explosions that just hit the sand directly in front of me. The bombs make a quiet thud, like one of our small, folding shovels striking a skull. Another jet bombs the enemy position and we return to digging our holes.
通过瞄准镜，这些爆炸看起来和我面前炮弹爆炸的规模差不多。炸弹发出沉闷的砰砰声，就像我们的小折叠铲击中头骨的声音。另一架喷气式飞机轰炸了敌方阵地，我们又回去挖我们的坑。
We have just experienced a formal exchange of fire. The reports will be forwarded to regimental and division S1. We've earned our combat action ribbons.
我们刚刚经历了一次正式的火力交换。报告将提交给团部和师部S1。我们赢得了战斗行动奖章。
At battalion, we learned that the final final deadlines for complete withdrawal from Kuwait are being issued to Saddam Hussein. And that the real battle, the mother of the mother's, is about to begin, within hours or the day. My battalion is one of four marine task forces from the First Marine Division crossing into Kuwait today. Our staff sergeant advises us to remove any foreign matter from our rucks. By foreign matter, he means letters from women other than our wives or girlfriends, and also pornography or other profane materials that wives and girlfriends and mothers might not like to receive after our deaths when our personal effects will be shipped to the states.
在营部，我们得知萨达姆·侯赛因收到了完全撤出科威特的最后最后期限。真正的战斗，“母亲之战中的母亲”，即将在几小时或一天内开始。我的营是今天进入科威特的第一海军陆战师的四个海军陆战队特遣部队之一。我们的上士建议我们移除背囊里的任何无关物品。所谓无关物品，指的是除了妻子或女朋友之外的女性写的信，以及妻子、女朋友和母亲在我们死后——当我们的个人物品被运回国内时——可能不想看到的色情或其他粗俗材料。
Johnny tells us to dig shallow shelters. [? Keen ?] complains about the heat. Doc John quizzes us on inserting breathing tubes, treating sucking chest wounds, and administering IVs. The Boot says something about missing his Harley-Davidson. And only feet above our heads, the sky splits open as a round passes over. The sound is like a thousand bolts of lightning striking at once. [? Keen ?] yells, what the [BLEEP] was that? Stay down, Johnny yells. [? Swoffe, ?] get me visual.
约翰尼告诉我们要挖浅掩体。[基恩]抱怨天气炎热。约翰·邓肯医生询问我们关于插入呼吸管、处理吸吮性胸部伤口以及静脉注射的问题。“菜鸟”说了些关于他想念哈雷摩托车的话。就在我们头顶几英尺处，天空裂开了，一枚炮弹呼啸而过。声音就像成千上万道闪电同时击中。 [基恩]大喊：“那他妈的是什么？”“趴下！”约翰尼大喊。“斯沃福，给我视觉信号！”
Rounds pass directly over our heads while I get my scope. As they pass over, it's as though all sound and time and space is sucked into the rounds. A five ton truck blows 100 yards behind us. Its water buffalo also blows into a large bloom of 500 gallons of water. Another five ton takes a hit.
炮弹直接从我们头顶掠过，我架起瞄准镜。当它们掠过时，就好像所有的声音、时间和空间都被吸进了炮弹里。我们身后100码处的一辆五吨卡车爆炸了。它的水箱也爆炸成了一团500加仑水的巨大云雾。另一辆五吨卡车被击中了。
I gain visual. The tank shooting at us are M60A1s. I yell to Johnny, it's our own tanks. He gets belly down on the deck and looks through my scope and says, it's friendlies.
我获得了视觉目标。向我们射击的坦克是M60A1。我向约翰尼大喊：“是我们自己的坦克。”他趴在地上，通过我的瞄准镜看了看，说：“是友军。”
The tank battalion is northeast of our position and even with their naked eyeballs, two grand out, they should have known we were friendly. Unlike the minor enemy assaults with artillery and rockets we've experienced, we know that our own guys will not stop until the entire convoy and all nearby personnel are annihilated because that is the way of the marine corps. We are fighting ourselves, but we can't shoot back.
坦克营在我们阵地的东北方，即使是肉眼，在两公里外，他们也应该知道我们是友军。与我们经历过的轻微炮弹和火箭弹袭击不同，我们知道，如果我们自己的部队不停止射击，直到整个车队和附近所有人员被歼灭，他们是不会罢休的，因为这就是海军陆战队的作风。我们在和自己人战斗，但我们不能开火还击。
More rounds pass over. Johnny dials the battalion's executive officer and asks, who the [BLEEP] do your tanks think they're shooting at to their southwest? It's [BLEEP] friendlies. It's me. It's my team you're shooting at. And our battalion, and the god damn supply convoy, you lousy [BLEEP].
更多的炮弹掠过。约翰尼拨通了营部执行官的电话，大喊：“你他妈的坦克觉得他们是在向西南方向射谁？那是他妈的友军！是我！你们射击的是我的小队，还有我们的营，还有该死的补给车队，你们这群烂混蛋！”
Johnny continues to scream and I hear in his voice astonishment and rage. Because of all the things that Johnny believes in, first he believes in the marine corps, and that the marine corps takes care of its own. As in doesn't kill its own.
约翰尼继续尖叫，我从他的声音里听到了震惊和愤怒。因为约翰尼相信的所有事情中，他首先相信的是海军陆战队，而且相信海军陆战队会照顾自己人。意思是说，不会杀自己人。
Word is that only two men died and six were injured at the hands of the trigger happy and blind tankers. I don't believe this because the damage is extreme. Three five tons and a humvee are burning. Lieutenants and sergeants are yelling up and down the ranks for us to start moving forward. The carnage is 100 yards behind me, but now my job is to forget it. There's still the god damn war here that we need to win.
据说只有两名士兵在这些盲目开火的坦克手手中死亡，六人受伤。我不相信这一点，因为破坏太严重了。三辆五吨卡车和一辆悍马正在燃烧。中尉和军士们在队列里大喊让我们开始向前推进。大屠杀就在我身后100码处，但现在我的工作是忘记它。我们还需要在这里赢得那场该死的战争。
Johnny and I are attached to Fox company in order to take part in the Third Battalion and Seventh Marines assault on Ahmed Al Jaber Airfield. The air control tower's our main target of interest. I read it at 800 yards and Johnny agrees. Enemy soldiers are moving inside the air control tower. An argument is occurring between two commanders. They point at each other's faces and gesture toward the enemy troops-- us. And I'm sure one man wants to fight and die and the other man wants to not fight and not die. The men scuffle and their troops pull them apart.
约翰尼和我被分配到福克斯连，以参加第三营第七团对艾哈迈德·贾比尔空军基地的攻击。空中管制塔台是我们主要的目标。我测出距离为800码，约翰尼表示同意。敌方士兵在控制塔内移动。两名指挥官之间发生了争执。他们互相指着对方的脸，并指向敌军——我们。我敢肯定一个人想战斗至死，而另一个人不想战斗也不想死。男人们打作一团，他们的士兵把他们拉开。
I request permission to take shots. The men in the tower are perfect targets. The windows are blown out of the tower and the men are standing. And I know that I can make a head shot. Johnny has already called the dope for the shot. He thinks I could take two people out in succession, the commander who wants to fight and one of his lieutenants. He thinks that the remaining men in the tower will surrender, plus however many soldiers are under that command. Perhaps the entire defensive posture at the airfield.
我申请开火许可。塔里的人是完美的靶子。塔楼的窗户被炸掉了，士兵们站在里面。我知道我可以做到爆头。约翰尼已经为射击准备好了数据。他认为我可以连续干掉两个人，那个想打仗的指挥官和他的一个中尉。他认为塔楼里剩下的士兵会投降，甚至是在那个指挥官管辖下的所有士兵都会投降。也许是空军基地的整个防御阵地。
The Fox company commander tells me over their freq, negative sierra tango one. Break. Negative on permission to shoot. Break. If their buddies next to them. Break. Start taking rounds in the head. Break. They won't surrender. Copy.
福克斯连指挥官通过频率告诉我：“否，塞拉探戈1号。暂停。拒绝射击许可。暂停。如果他们的伙伴就在旁边。暂停。开始射击头部。暂停。他们是不会投降的。收到。”
I want to say, screw you, sir. Copy. But I reply, roger, roger.
我真想说：“去你的，长官。收到。”但我回答：“收到，收到。”
I can't help but assume that certain commanders at the company level don't want to use us because they know that two snipers with two of the finest rifles in the world and a few hundred rounds between them, will in a short time devastate the enemy, causing the entire airfield to surrender. The captains want war as badly as we do and they must know that the possibilities are dwindling.
我不禁认为，连级的某些指挥官不想用我们，是因为他们知道，两名拥有两支世界上最精良步枪和几百发子弹的狙击手，会在短时间内摧毁敌人，导致整个机场投降。上尉们和我们一样渴望战争，他们一定知道这种可能性正在减少。
Also, the same as us, the captains want no war. But here it is. And when you're a captain with a company to command and two snipers want to take a dozen easy shots and try to call it a day, of course you tell them no. Because you are a captain and you have a company of infantry and what you need is some war ink spilled on your service record book.
同样，和我们一样，上尉们也不想要战争。但它就摆在这里。当你是一名指挥着连队、并且有两名狙击手想用一打简单的射击就搞定战斗的上尉时，你当然会告诉他们“不行”。因为你是一名上尉，你有一个步兵连，而你需要的是在你的军旅记录本上写下一些“战争的墨迹”。
The combat engineers blow two breaches in the eastern fence line. And as the dark oil fire smoke gets darker, and the sky blackens like midnight even though it's only 1700, the infantry assault companies enter the airfield and we watch. We watched the grunts moving like mules. We watch the smoke. And we hear the resulting confusion over the freq.
战斗工兵在东侧围栏线炸开了两个缺口。当暗淡的油火浓烟变得越来越黑，尽管现在才下午5点，天空却黑得像午夜，步兵突击连进入了机场，我们看着。我们看着步兵像骡子一样移动。我们看着浓烟。我们听着频率里传来的混乱声。
At the fence line nearest us, a platoon of Iraqis appears waving white towels and smiling. There's no one there to accept them and the men push themselves against the fence, as writers might at a soccer match. They then sit and stretch out in the sand, as though the war is over.
在我们最近的围栏线上，出现了一排挥舞着白毛巾并微笑着的伊拉克人。那里没有人接收他们，士兵们把自己贴在围栏上，就像足球比赛的观众一样。然后他们坐下来，在沙地上伸展身体，好像战争已经结束了。
No one has called Johnny and me for hours. The airfield assault continues and the fence line platoon of surrendering Iraqis remains. Some of the men smoking casually and eating canned rations.
几个小时没人叫约翰尼和我了。机场袭击仍在继续，围栏线上投降的伊拉克排依然待在那里。有些人悠闲地抽着烟，吃着罐头口粮。
Because I'm angry and frustrated over being ignored, I tell Johnny I want to shoot one of the Iraqis and I spend half an hour hopping from head to head with my cross hairs yelling, bang, bang. You're a dead [BLEEP] Iraqi.
因为被忽视，我很生气和沮丧，我告诉约翰尼我想射杀其中一个伊拉克人，我花了半个小时用我的准星在他们的头上来回瞄准，大喊着：“砰，砰。你这个该死的伊拉克鬼子。”
We hear medevac requests over the freq and mortars are called in to support the grunts. And in a few hours, the assault is over and I've remained a spectator.
我们在频率里听到医疗后送的请求，并呼叫迫击炮来支援步兵。几个小时后，袭击结束了，我依然是一个旁观者。
After a few days, the war ends. The cleanup mission is a freelance operation. We gear up in our three humvees and head out each morning from the battalion bivouac. We run with glee through the enemy positions, noting the hundreds of different ways a man might die when 500 pound bombs are dropped on his badly fortified position.
几天后，战争结束了。清理任务是自由行动。我们每天早上从营部宿营地出发，开着我们的三辆悍马。我们满怀喜悦地跑过敌人的阵地，注意着当500磅的炸弹投在他加固糟糕的阵地上时，一个人可能会死去的几百种方式。
Some of the corpses in the bunkers are hunched over, hands covering their ears, as though they had been waiting in dread. Many seemed to have died not from shrapnel, but concussion. And dried, discolored blood gathers around their eyes and ears and noses and mouths. No obvious trauma to their bodies.
掩体里的一些尸体蜷缩着，双手捂着耳朵，好像他们在恐惧中等待着。许多人似乎不是死于弹片，而是死于震荡。干燥、变色的血迹聚集在他们的眼睛、耳朵、鼻子和嘴巴周围。身体上没有明显的创伤。
A few weeks into the air campaign, the United States rolled out the daisy cutter bomb. The daisy cutter spread a mixture of ammonium nitrate and aluminum over the target area, and then ignited the cloud. If you were within two acres and exposed above ground, or even in a barricaded bunker, you were sure to die.
空袭战役进行几周后，美国推出了“雏菊切割机”炸弹。“雏菊切割机”在目标区域上方散布了硝酸铵和铝粉的混合物，然后点燃了这团云。如果你在两英亩以内并且在地面以上，或者即使是在加固的掩体中，你也注定会死亡。
The infantry positions looked like daisy cutter test areas. The mouths of the dead men remain open in agony.
步兵阵地看起来像是“雏菊切割机”的试验场。死者的嘴巴痛苦地张着。
After our battalion gets its turn at a victory lap around Kuwait City, the captain from S3 suggests STA get together with him and the few enlisted marines from his shop and that we all fire the weapons that STA has gathered from the enemy positions. Our cache is 400 to 500 AKs and 3 dozen RPGs.
在我们营绕科威特城进行了一圈胜利巡游后，来自S3的上尉建议STA和他们部门的几名士兵聚在一起，让我们大家试射STA从敌方阵地收集来的武器。我们的库存里有400到500支AK步枪和3打RPG。
The Iraqi soldiers took poor care of their rifles. We've pried some of the weapons from the hands of dead men, and the pitiful state of the weapons, the rust, the filthy barrels, and the sand filled trigger mechanisms, now leads us to curse the men and their sloppy soldiering.
伊拉克士兵对他们的步枪维护得很差。我们从死人手中撬出了一些武器，武器的悲惨状况——锈迹、肮脏的枪管和塞满沙子的触发机制——现在让我们诅咒那些人和他们草率的军人作风。
We stand in a firing line and shoot the AKs. I feel like a traitor holding the enemy's weapon. Now firing the enemy's weapon, the snap, snap, snap of the firing pin piercing the shell. The projectiles screaming down range. I don't care what I hit: desert, tanks, bunkers, troop carriers. And still in some of the carriers: corpses.
我们站在射击线上射击AK步枪。拿着敌人的武器，我感觉自己像个叛徒。现在射击敌人的武器，击针刺穿弹壳发出“咔哒、咔哒”的声音。射弹呼啸着飞向远方。我不在乎我击中了什么：沙漠、坦克、掩体、运兵车。那些运兵车里甚至还有尸体。
Next to me, my platoon mates also fire from the hip with no precision, as though we're famous and immortal, and we burn through the magazines.
在我旁边，我的排友们也毫无准头地从腰际开火，仿佛我们是著名且不朽的，我们打光了弹夹。
It's a factory of firepower. The fierce scream of metal down range and discharged cartridges and sand flying everywhere. Now all of us shooting in the air, shooting straight up and dancing in circles, with the mad idea that the rounds will not descend. Screaming. Screaming at ourselves and one another and the dead Iraqis surrounding us. Screaming at ourselves, the corpses surrounding us, and the dead world.
这是一个火力工厂。金属尖锐的啸叫声飞向远处，弹壳和沙子到处乱飞。现在我们所有人都向空中射击，垂直向上射击，跳着圈旋转，带着那种弹头不会降落的疯狂想法。尖叫着。对自己、对彼此、对周围死去的伊拉克人尖叫。对自己、对自己周围的尸体和这个死寂的世界尖叫。
Anthony Swofford reading from his memoir about the 1991 Persian Gulf War. It's called Jarhead. It comes out in March.
安东尼·斯沃福德朗读他关于1991年波斯湾战争的回忆录。书名是《罐头人》。三月份出版。
Coming up, John Hodgman solves a problem that's been bothering millions-- millions-- including maybe, I think, maybe just you. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，约翰·霍奇曼将解决一个困扰数百万人的问题——包括，我想，可能就是你。那一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和美国公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, The Real Story. In war of course, the first casualty is truth. We bring you four stories of what really happened in four different wars. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act two, What's the Truth Got to Do With It?
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，带给你各种关于这个主题的故事。今天的节目是《真实的故事》。当然，在战争中，第一个牺牲品就是真相。我们为你带来四个关于在四场不同战争中到底发生了什么的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《真相到底有什么用？》
This is one of those stories that people who closely follow this kind of thing have known for years. If you're a regular public radio listener you may have heard of this. But if you're like me, your sense of it has always been kind of vague.
这是一个长期关注此类问题的人多年来都知道的故事之一。如果你是公共广播的常客，你可能听说过这个。但如果你像我一样，你的印象总是模糊的。
I turned a corner on this story a couple months ago when I met this Israeli named BZ Goldberg. And he started telling me about how, not too long back, he read one of these new histories about the state of Israel. There are these books written by Israelis that go back and take a look at what the Jews did in the early days of their country.
几个月前，当我遇到这位叫BZ·戈德堡的以色列人时，我对这个故事有了新的认识。他开始告诉我，不久前，他读了一本关于以色列国的新历史书。这些书是由以色列人写的，他们回过头来审视犹太人在建国初期做了什么。
It was like reading a suspense novel because I would read through it and on one page he would say something and I would say, no. No, that's not-- no, no, no. And I would go to the next page and say, no, that didn't-- no. No, that's not what I learned in grade school.
这就像读一本悬疑小说，因为我会一直读下去，在某一页他会说一些话，我会说：“不。不，不是这样的……不，不，不。”然后我会翻到下一页说：“不，没发生过那种事……不。不，那不是我在小学学到的。”
One story that struck him hard reading these books, there was proof that back in the '40s, Israeli soldiers sometimes forced Arabs off their land and out of the country, keeping the land for Jews. That is pretty much exactly the opposite of the story that BZ heard back in school.
有一个故事让他感触颇深，读到这些书时，书中证明了早在40年代，以色列士兵有时会将阿拉伯人赶出他们的土地和国家，并为犹太人占领这些土地。这与BZ在学校听到的故事几乎完全相反。
I remember this teacher I had in junior high school who told us how the Israeli forces went from Arab village to Arab village trying to convince the local Arabs to stay. And the idea was they said, please, we want to be your neighbors. Don't leave. And we begged them. We asked them. We pleaded.
我记得我在初中时有一位老师，他告诉我们以色列军队是如何从一个阿拉伯村庄走到另一个阿拉伯村庄，试图说服当地阿拉伯人留下来。他们的想法是，他们会说：“求求你们，我们想成为你们的邻居。别走。”我们恳求他们。我们问他们。我们哀求他们。
And that was something I believed until I was in my 20s, or maybe 30s even.
这就是我直到20多岁，甚至30多岁时一直相信的事情。
Just a few weeks after I met BZ, I traveled to Israel to do some stories for our radio show. And one of the things I looked into was these historians. I picked up their books. I talked to some people. I wanted to finally understand once and for all, what happened between the Israelis and the Arabs back when Israel became a state?
在我见到BZ几周后，我前往以色列为我们的广播节目制作一些故事。我调查的事情之一就是这些历史学家。我拿起他们的书。我采访了一些人。我终于想彻底弄清楚，在以色列建国时，以色列人和阿拉伯人之间到底发生了什么。
Roughly 700,000 out of 800,000 Arabs left their homes, abandoned their country in less than a year. Why? It was like the back story to today's politics between Israelis and Palestinians that nobody ever really bothers to explain.
大约80万阿拉伯人中有70万人离开了家园，在不到一年的时间里放弃了他们的国家。为什么？这就像今天以色列人和巴勒斯坦人之间政治纠纷的背景故事，却从来没有人真正费心去解释。
We did not have history, we had indoctrination. We had mythology.
我们没有历史，我们只有灌输。我们只有神话。
Tom Segev is the man who wrote the first of these new histories, or as they're better known in Israel, revisionist histories. He says it wasn't possible to write a real history of Israel until the early 1980s when under Israeli law, the state archives released most of the government documents from Israel's early years. Among the findings there for historians, the diaries of David Ben-Gurion, the man who founded the modern state of Israel.
汤姆·塞格夫是撰写第一部这类新历史的人，或者像他们在以色列众所周知的那样，修正主义历史。他说，直到20世纪80年代初，根据以色列法律，国家档案馆解密了以色列建国初期的大部分政府文件，才有可能编写一部真实的以色列历史。历史学家在那里的发现中，有大卫·本-古里安的日记，他是现代以色列国的缔造者。
The diary of Ben-Gurion is an incredible document. In that Ben-Gurion wrote every day. In fact, every hour. He wrote his diary during meetings, even with people. He wrote down everything he heard and everything he thought. It's an incredible diary. He did that since the age of 14 or 15, I think, to the very end of his life. And in little notebooks. And at the end of each notebook, he would prepare an index for that particular notebook.
本-古里安的日记是一份令人难以置信的文件。本-古里安每天都在里面写东西。事实上，每小时。他在会议期间，甚至在与人交流时，都会写日记。他写下了他听到和想到的一切。这是一份不可思议的日记。我想他从14或15岁开始一直写到生命的尽头。用小笔记本写的。在每个笔记本的末尾，他还会为那个特定的笔记本准备一个索引。
Some of the things that Segev and the other historians found was surprising. Not only because they had happened, but because somebody had actually put them down on paper.
塞格夫和其他历史学家发现的一些事情令人震惊。不仅是因为它们发生了，还因为有人真的把它们写在了纸上。
I remember that I was shocked and I also know that one of the chapters that actually shocked people was a detailed account of how Israelis looted Arab property. I mean, in some way, this makes it more concrete than just talking about 700,000 people left their houses. When you ask, so what happened to the carpets? What happened to the radio sets? What happened to the chairs and where did all this go? And I found documents about that as well. I mean, very, very critical reports written by government officials at the time.
我记得我很震惊，我也知道其中一个实际上让人们震惊的章节是对以色列人如何掠夺阿拉伯财产的详细记录。我的意思是，在某种程度上，这比仅仅谈论70万人口离开了他们的房子更具体。当你问，那么地毯怎么样了？收音机怎么样了？椅子怎么样了，这些东西都去哪了？我也发现了关于这方面的文件。我的意思是，当时政府官员写的非常、非常严厉的报告。
Some quick background might be useful before we go any further into this. All the events that led to the Arabs evacuating Israel happened in just a few months. At the beginning of the war, the Israelis call the War of Independence and the Arabs call the Disaster of the Catastrophe.
在我们深入探讨之前，一些背景知识可能很有用。导致阿拉伯人撤离以色列的所有事件都发生在短短几个月内。在战争开始时，以色列人称之为“独立战争”，而阿拉伯人称之为“大灾难”。
Before the war, Jews had been steadily emigrating to the country for decades, living side by side with the Arabs. Though, sometimes not too peacefully.
战争前，几十年来犹太人一直在稳定地移民到这个国家，与阿拉伯人并肩生活。虽然，有时并不是很和平。
In 1947, the UN proposed a way that everybody could get along. Divide the territory into two separate countries, one Jewish, one Arab. The Jews said sure. They were lucky to get this much. The Arabs said never, thinking that it was on its face outrageous that these newcomers should get anything. And then the Arabs launched a war against the Jews.
1947年，联合国提出了一个大家都能和睦相处的方案。将领土划分为两个独立的国家，一个是犹太国，一个是阿拉伯国。犹太人说“当然”。能得到这么多他们已经很幸运了。阿拉伯人说“绝不”，认为这些新来者应该得到任何东西简直是荒谬。然后阿拉伯人对犹太人发动了战争。
If you want the big picture on why most of the Arab population of the country left Israel during that war, the best book is probably by Benny Morris, a book with a very dry sounding title The Birth of the Palestinian Refugee Problem 1947-1949.
如果你想全面了解为什么在该战争期间，这个国家的大部分阿拉伯人口离开了以色列，最好的书可能是本尼·莫里斯写的，书名非常枯燥：《巴勒斯坦难民问题的产生 1947-1949》。
It is kind of an amazing book, starting with the maps right at the front, where Morris annotates what happened to the Arabs in 369 different villages that he's researched one by one.
这是一本非常棒的书，开头就有地图，莫里斯在地图上逐一注释了他研究的369个不同村庄里的阿拉伯人发生了什么。
What happened he said is complicated. And he says it changes over time. Sometimes Arabs ran away on their own, sometimes Arabs were forcibly expelled. Sometimes Arabs were encouraged to run away by the Israelis. But at the beginning of the war-- Benny Morris is quite clear on this. At the beginning of the war, there was no grand Jewish plan to expel Arabs from their homes.
他说发生的事情很复杂。他说情况随着时间而改变。有时阿拉伯人自己逃跑了，有时阿拉伯人被强行驱逐。有时阿拉伯人受到以色列人的鼓励而逃跑。但在战争初期——本尼·莫里斯对此非常清楚。在战争初期，并没有一个宏大的犹太计划去将阿拉伯人从他们的家中驱逐出去。
There wasn't a general plan. There wasn't a master plan. And there wasn't even in the course of '48, a policy to expel Arabs. Though Arab propagandists and historians, or so-called historians, still tout this same Arab version. Official Zionist policy, and this was also the policy carried out in the field by the Jewish troops, was to leave the Arab population in place.
没有总计划。没有主计划。甚至在48年的进程中，也没有驱逐阿拉伯人的政策。尽管阿拉伯宣传家和历史学家，或者所谓的历史学家，仍然在兜售这种阿拉伯版本的说法。官方的犹太复国主义政策，以及犹太军队在实地执行的政策，是让阿拉伯人口留在原地。
And that was true until the Israelis started losing the war in March of 1948. Things were looking bad for them and they knew that they were going to get a lot worse. That Syria, Egypt, Lebanon, Transjordan and Iraq were all about to invade with their armies. So the Israelis went on the offense, attacking Arab villages, Arab towns, Arab neighborhoods.
这种情况一直持续到1948年3月以色列开始在战争中失利。局势对他们来说看起来很糟糕，而且他们知道情况会变得更糟。叙利亚、埃及、黎巴嫩、外约旦和伊拉克都准备用他们的军队入侵。因此，以色列人转而发起进攻，攻击阿拉伯村庄、城镇和社区。
In one operation called Plan D, the idea was simply to clear away Arabs who were sniping at roads and at supply routes that the Jews were using in the growing war. But Jewish troops discovered, and records showed that they were truly surprised at this. That whenever they would move into an area, the Arabs would just flee en masse.
在名为“D计划”的一次行动中，其想法仅仅是清除那些在犹太人在日益激烈的战争中使用的道路和补给线上狙击的阿拉伯人。但犹太军队发现——记录显示他们对此感到非常惊讶——每当他们进入一个地区时，阿拉伯人就会集体逃离。
And most of the populations in fact, fled as battle approached, and as the Jews began to attack. Most Arabs fled so there wasn't even a need to expel them in the sense of a unit moving into a village and ordering the population out. The population fled before the unit entered the village.
事实上，当战斗临近，当犹太人开始进攻时，大多数人口都逃跑了。大多数阿拉伯人逃跑了，所以甚至不需要以部队进入村庄并命令人口撤离的方式来驱逐他们。在部队进入村庄之前，人口就已经逃跑了。
I was talking to an Israeli who told me that he remembers being taught in school as a kid. The teacher said, the Israeli army went from village to village and begged the Arabs to stay. Please stay. Please be our neighbors. Did that happen in places?
我和一位以色列人谈过，他告诉我他记得小时候在学校里被教导的内容。老师说，以色列军队从一个村庄走到另一个村庄，恳求阿拉伯人留下来。“请留下来。请成为我们的邻居。”这在某些地方发生过吗？
It did happen, but what happens in collective memory and in official memory, is that things are telescoped. In other words, what happened in one or two villages at certain points in time, and actually also in city of Haifa on the 22 of April, where Jewish officials asked neighboring Arabs to stay, it's telescoped and expanded to cover the whole range of the war and all various different places. But it only happened in specific places and specific times at the beginning of the war. By the end of April, basically, there was a consensus on the Jewish side, it's best that the Arabs leave. And nobody asked Arabs to stay after the end of April. Anywhere.
它确实发生过，但在集体记忆和官方记忆中，事情被“缩减”了。换句话说，在特定时间点发生在这一两个村庄的事情，实际上也发生在4月22日海法的城市，当时犹太官员要求邻近的阿拉伯人留下来，这些事例被缩减和扩大，覆盖了整个战争范围和所有不同的地方。但它只发生在战争初期特定地点和特定时间。到四月底，基本上，在犹太方面达成了共识，最好让阿拉伯人离开。四月底之后，没有人再要求阿拉伯人留下来。任何地方都没有。
In fact, by the end of April, once they saw how quickly the Arabs had fled, and how much easier things were for the Jews with them gone, the Jews started to realize that they could end up with something that they had never dared to dream of when the war began. A new state that was nearly entirely Jewish, with very few Arabs in it. And they started to lay the groundwork for that to happen.
事实上，到四月底，一旦他们看到阿拉伯人逃跑得有多快，且他们离开后犹太人的情况变得多么容易，犹太人开始意识到他们最终可能会得到一个他们在战争开始时从未敢梦想的东西。一个几乎全是犹太人的新国家，里面几乎没有阿拉伯人。他们开始为实现这一目标奠定基础。
When Arabs started asking if they could return to their homes-- and they started asking just weeks after they left. The war was still going on. Arab farmers wanted to get to their fields and orchards. People wanted to get to their houses now that they knew that the shooting had stopped in some areas. The Zionist leaders told them no, you can't come back.
当阿拉伯人开始询问他们是否可以回到自己的家园时——他们离开几周后就开始问了。战争还在继续。阿拉伯农民想回到他们的田地和果园。现在他们知道在一些地区射击已经停止，人们想回到他们的房子里。犹太复国主义领导人告诉他们：“不，你不能回来。”
And the thinking was really very simple. Militarily, it was understood that these Arabs would launch the war against Israel and we're supporting the Arab states in their invasion of Palestine, which was aimed basically at stopping the emergence of a Jewish state. These Arabs were a fifth column. If they were allowed back, they would be a fifth column, undermining, subverting, and perhaps, attacking the state from within. This was clear to everybody.
这种想法其实非常简单。从军事上讲，人们明白这些阿拉伯人发动了针对以色列的战争，并支持阿拉伯国家入侵巴勒斯坦，这本质上是为了阻止犹太国家的出现。这些阿拉伯人是“第五纵队”。如果让他们回来，他们将是“第五纵队”，从内部破坏、颠覆甚至攻击这个国家。这对每个人来说都很清楚。
Once the Arabs had fled, they said, well, that's it. They attacked us. They fled. This is justice. Had the Arabs not launched a war there would have been no refugee problem. We will not let them back. Letting them back in would be putting a time bomb in our midst. That's how they saw it.
一旦阿拉伯人逃跑，他们就会说：“好吧，就是这样。他们攻击我们。他们逃跑了。这就是正义。”如果阿拉伯人没有发动战争，就不会有难民问题。我们不会让他们回来。让他们回来就是在我们中间埋下一颗定时炸弹。他们就是这样看的。
And all that made sense while Israel was still openly at war. It was at the end of the war that the Jews made what Benny Morris calls, "A morally questionable decision" to never let the Arabs come back.
当以色列还处于公开战争状态时，这一切都说得通。直到战争结束时，犹太人才做出了本尼·莫里斯所说的“道德上令人怀疑的决定”，即永远不让阿拉伯人回来。
They leveled Arab towns, took Arab fields, took Arab houses because they wanted all that for the new Jewish state. This would allow settlements to expand. They would make more room for immigrants. And it would mean that Jews would be a solid majority in the Jewish state.
他们推平了阿拉伯城镇，夺取了阿拉伯的田地，占有了阿拉伯的房屋，因为他们想要为新犹太国家获取这一切。这将使定居点得以扩张。他们会为移民腾出更多空间。这意味着犹太人将在犹太国家中成为稳固的多数。
One person who saw all this happen was Ahmun Hadari.
艾哈蒙·哈达里就是见证这一切发生的人之一。
There's a very nice village on the shore, an Arab village, a large one called Achziv. We found it empty. Everybody had run away. All the Palestinians had run away.
岸边有一个非常漂亮的村庄，一个阿拉伯村庄，一个叫阿赫齐夫的大村庄。我们发现它空无一人。每个人都跑了。所有的巴勒斯坦人都跑了。
At the age of 19 in 1948, Ahmun fought in Israel's War of Independence. And that same year, he was also one of the founders of a Jewish settlement called Gesher Haziv, up near the Lebanese border, by this abandoned town of Achziv. Achziv, he tells me, is mentioned in the Bible as one of the towns that the ancient Israelites were never able to capture from the local population. Now there's a Club Med there, by the way.
1948年19岁时，艾哈蒙参加了以色列的独立战争。同一年，他还是一个名为盖舍尔·哈齐夫的犹太定居点的创始人之一，就在黎巴嫩边境附近，在那座废弃的阿赫齐夫镇旁边。他告诉我，阿赫齐夫在《圣经》中被提到，是古代以色列人无法从当地居民手中夺取的城镇之一。顺便说一句，现在那里有一个地中海俱乐部。
Ahmun pulls out a snapshot of himself from 1948, lean and young, standing in the sun.
艾哈蒙拿出一张1948年他自己的快照，身材瘦削，年轻，站在阳光下。
Now, not where I'm standing, but a little in my background there, it was an Arab village. You don't see the village, but these were its fields. What we got when we settled there was a piece of very fertile ground that had already been worked for quite-- I don't know how many years. Probably hundreds.
现在，不是我站的地方，但在我背景里的一点，那是一个阿拉伯村庄。你看不到村庄，但这些是它的田地。当我们在这里定居时，我们得到的是一片非常肥沃的土地，它已经被耕作了很久——我不知道有多少年。可能有几百年了。
At the time, we did not feel that there was anything really drastically wrong with that. About a year after we settled, some old and decrepit and sick Palestinians-- they didn't call themselves Palestinians in those days-- had come back and were now living at the outskirts of town. And there was a call up by the local military commander, one of the members of the kibbutz, taking 12 or 15 young men with rifles down there to chase them away. They chased them away and the next night they were back again. So the night after that, we brought a truck. Or they brought a truck, I wasn't there. They put them on the truck and they took them all the way up to the Lebanese border. And told them, OK, find a way of infiltrating back into Lebanon. That was that.
当时，我们并不觉得那有什么真正严重的错误。我们在那里定居大约一年后，一些年老、残疾和生病的巴勒斯坦人——那时候他们不叫自己巴勒斯坦人——回来了，现在住在城镇郊区。当地军事指挥官，也就是基布兹（集体农庄）的一名成员，下达了征召令，带着12或15名拿着步枪的年轻人下去把他们赶走。他们把他们赶走了，第二天晚上他们又回来了。所以在那之后的晚上，我们带来了一辆卡车。或者他们带来了一辆卡车，我不在场。他们把他们装上卡车，把他们一直带到黎巴嫩边境。并告诉他们：“好了，自己想办法潜回黎巴嫩吧。”事情就是这样。
So how is it that living on that kibbutz with the village always standing there by the beach where you were going to swim, how was it that you didn't think about it all the time, oh, we took this from other people?
那么，住在那个基布兹，村庄就在你去游泳的海滩边，你怎么就不会一直想：“哦，我们是从别人那里抢来的？”
Let me sound like a demagogue for just one minute. You're from Chicago? You know of Fort Dearborn? When you go to Fort Dearborn, do you see Indians being slaughtered by white people from Europe with muskets? It just doesn't enter into the equation.
让我像个煽动者一样说一分钟。你是芝加哥人吗？你知道迪尔伯恩堡吗？当你去迪尔伯恩堡时，你会看到欧洲白人用火枪屠杀印第安人吗？它只是没有进入方程。
In every war, there are winners and losers. The winners, in order to feel like they're winners, try not to think too much about the losers.
在每一场战争中，都有赢家和输家。赢家为了感觉自己是赢家，尽量不去多想输家。
Lots of Israelis, especially the religious half of the population, still believe that God gave this land to the Jews just like it says in the Bible and the events 50 years ago really don't change anything for them. Polls show that 40% of Israeli Jews think they have a right, even to the occupied territories. Still, these revisionist histories have been around since the late '80s. There have been TV reports and specials. The findings have trickled into high school textbooks. How much has it penetrated into the way that Israelis think about their country? Do many Israelis ever think about it?
许多以色列人，尤其是人口中宗教那一半，仍然相信上帝把这片土地给了犹太人，就像《圣经》里说的那样，50年前发生的事件对他们来说真的没有改变任何东西。民意调查显示，40%的以色列犹太人认为他们有权甚至拥有被占领土。尽管如此，这些修正主义历史从80年代末开始就一直存在。有电视报道和专题节目。这些发现已渗透到高中教科书里。它在多大程度上渗透进了以色列人看待自己国家的方式中？有多少以色列人会去想这个问题？
Take one of the most disturbing and best known incidents that happened during the war in '48. At two towns, right near the airport when you fly  into Israel, Lod and Ramle, the largest mass eviction of Arabs came from there. And we know about it partly because Yitzhak Rabin, the architect of the Oslo Peace Accords, one of Israel's prime ministers, wrote about it in his autobiography. Again, historian Tom Segev.
举一个战争期间最令人不安且众所周知的事情。在两个城镇，当你飞往以色列时就在机场附近，卢德和拉姆勒，那是阿拉伯人最大规模的强行驱逐。我们知道这一点是因为以色列的首相之一、奥斯陆和平协议的设计者伊扎克·拉宾在自传中写过它。再次提到历史学家汤姆·塞格夫。
He tells a story of how he really didn't know what to do when he headed the forces who occupied these two towns. He really didn't know what to do with the population, and so we went to David Ben-Gurion himself and asked him, what do we do with these people? And Ben-Gurion made some gesture with his hand.
他讲了一个故事，说拉宾在领导占领这两个城镇的部队时，真的不知道该怎么办。他真的不知道该拿这些人口怎么办，所以他去找大卫·本-古里安本人，问他：“我们该拿这些人怎么办？”而本-古里安用手做了个手势。
A gesture in midair, like somebody briskly sweeping away some crumbs.
半空中一个手势，就像有人在轻快地扫走一些面包屑。
Which Rabin interpreted as meaning, get rid of them. Expel them. And this is exactly what happened.
拉宾将其解释为意味着“把他们赶走”。“驱逐他们。”这就是后来发生的事情。
It looks like an old house, or just this stone, very long stone wall with arches inside and windows, but it's completely overgrown with weeds.
看起来像一座古老的房子，或者仅仅是这块石头，非常长的石墙，里面有拱门和窗户，但它完全被杂草覆盖了。
While I was in Israel, I visited Lod and Ramle with Adam Davidson. If you heard our show from Israel, you probably recognize Adam, a regular contributor to our program. He's half Israeli and half American, fluent in Hebrew.
当我在以色列时，我和亚当·戴维森一起参观了卢德和拉姆勒。如果你听过我们关于以色列的节目，你可能认出亚当，他是我们节目的常客。他是半以色列半美国人，精通希伯来语。
We asked a taxi to drive us around. Arabs still live here, some of them descendants of the few hundred Arabs left behind in 1948. As we drive, Adam asks our cab driver if he's heard the story about the expulsion. The cab driver who's Jewish says that that story is impossible.
我们让出租车带我们四处转转。阿拉伯人仍然住在这里，其中一些是1948年留下的几百名阿拉伯人的后代。当我们开车时，亚当问我们的出租车司机是否听说过那个驱逐的故事。那个是犹太人的出租车司机说那个故事是不可能的。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
（希伯来语交谈）
He said that it's always been Jews here. It's always been Jew. And how is that possible that people would be kicked out? It doesn't make sense.
他说这里一直都是犹太人。一直都是。怎么可能有人会被赶走？这不合逻辑。
But Rabin wrote it himself in his biography.
但拉宾在传记里亲自写下了这一点。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
（希伯来语交谈）
He says it didn't happen. He doesn't believe it could happen because they were part of us. We lived here together. We were all unified.
他说那没有发生。他不相信那会发生，因为他们是“我们的一部分”。我们住在一起。我们都是统一的。
The cab driver goes on like this, incredulous. He thinks Adam and I are just terribly misinformed. We keep driving, looking for a shopping mall where we can interview people about the town's history. Our cab driver knows about one, but he cannot find it. And he keeps pulling over asking for directions from people on the street. Every time he does this, the same thing happens.
出租车司机就这样怀疑地继续说着。他认为亚当和我只是极其缺乏信息。我们继续开车，寻找一个购物中心，以便采访人们关于城镇的历史。我们的出租车司机知道一个，但他找不到。他不断地停下来问路人。每次他这样做时，同样的事情就会发生。
First, he rolls down his window and he asks about the mall.
首先，他摇下窗户，询问购物中心。
[SPEAKNIG HEBREW]
（希伯来语交谈）
Then, after he gets directions, he asks them, have you heard this story about 1948 and Rabin?
然后，在得到方向后，他问他们：“你听说过关于1948年和拉宾的那个故事吗？”
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
（希伯来语交谈）
A Jewish woman scolds us. Keep going, get out of here. A man shakes his head.
一个犹太妇女责骂我们。“走开，离开这儿。”一个男人摇摇头。
He said, leave me alone in quiet. Leave me in quiet, my brother.
他说：“让我安静地待着。让我安静点，我的兄弟。”
When we get to the mall and out on the street afterwards, we talk with Arabs and Jews. Every Arab we meet in Lod and Ramle had heard the story of how Arabs were expelled in 1948. Nearly none of the Jews knew this story. This Jewish man used to teach high school history.
当我们到达商场以及随后的街上时，我们与阿拉伯人和犹太人交谈。我们在卢德和拉姆勒遇到的每个阿拉伯人都听说过1948年阿拉伯人被驱逐的故事。几乎没有犹太人知道这个故事。这个犹太人曾经教过高中历史。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
（希伯来语交谈）
He says he's taught a lot of course and given a lot of lectures about war and he's never heard this in his life. Maybe he has and he forgot, but he doesn't think he has.
他说他教过很多课程，做过很多关于战争的演讲，他一生中从未听说过这个。也许他听过但他忘了，但他认为他没听过。
We kind of live this double life. On the one hand we know all this and at the other hand, we ignore it, or we don't want to know it.
我们有点活在这种双重生活中。一方面我们知道这一切，而另一方面，我们忽视它，或者我们不想知道它。
Here's BZ Goldberg, the Israeli who got me into all this in the first place. He says those stories that he heard back in school were really nice stories.
这是BZ·戈德堡，最初带我进入这一切的以色列人。他说他在学校听到的那些故事确实是很棒的故事。
Because I was, I guess, young when I heard this, there's still something in me that wants to believe that actually, that that really happened, that story that I heard. That we did beg them to stay.
因为我猜我听到的时候还年轻，我内心深处依然有一些东西想相信那是真的，那个故事是我听到的……我们确实恳求他们留下来。
That's funny, like there's a part of you that kind of believes the storybook version.
这很有趣，好像你内心有一部分人相信故事书里的版本。
There's a part of me that desperately wants to believe the storybook version. We desperately want to believe that we're good. We want to do the right thing and we want to believe that we have been doing the right thing.
我内心有一部分人迫切地想相信故事书里的版本。我们迫切地想相信我们是好的。我们想做正确的事情，我们想相信我们一直在做正确的事情。
There's a political side to this too. Officially, the Israeli government denies that it was responsible for Arabs leaving the country in 1948. Because if it admitted any responsibility, the Arabs who left, and their kids and grandkids, basically all the people who today we know as the Palestinians, they would try to use that to make Israel let them back in. Barely any Israelis want to see that.
这也有政治层面。官方上，以色列政府否认它对1948年阿拉伯人离开国家负有责任。因为如果它承认任何责任，那些离开的阿拉伯人，以及他们的孩子和孙子——基本上就是我们今天所知的巴勒斯坦人——他们会试图利用这一点让以色列让他们回来。几乎没有以色列人愿意看到这一点。
Even historian Benny Morris, who believes the Israelis do bear some responsibility for the existence of the refugees, who literally wrote the book on it, even he does not want to let the Palestinians back in.
即使是相信以色列确实对难民的存在负有一定责任、并且确实写了相关书籍的历史学家本尼·莫里斯，即使是他也不想让巴勒斯坦人回来。
If they are allowed back into the country, if Israel admits, agrees to the right of return, which the Palestinians demand, this will mean that Israel will be inundated, flooded by Palestinian refugees, and instantly become a country with a Jewish minority. It will cease being a Jewish state. It means in fact, self destruction. It means suicide. So I think Israel must refuse to accept responsibility and the right of return.
如果他们被允许回到这个国家，如果以色列承认、同意巴勒斯坦人要求的回归权，这意味着以色列将被巴勒斯坦难民淹没，并瞬间成为一个拥有犹太少数群体的国家。它将不再是一个犹太国家。这实际上意味着自我毁灭。这意味着自杀。所以我认为以色列必须拒绝承担责任和接受回归权。
It seems that you're put into the position though, where as a historian, in a way, you're endorsing the government officially denying part of the truth of its own history?
但作为一个历史学家，你似乎被置于这样一种位置：在某种程度上，你在支持政府官方否认其自身历史的部分真相？
No, I don't do that. I've always professed and that's what drove me and still drives me in my historical writing that people should know the truth about their past. But it's not necessary to translate truth into policy. There's no one to one connection between truth and policy.
不，我没有那样做。我一直主张，这也是驱使我并在我的历史写作中依然驱使我的原因，人们应该了解他们过去的真相。但没必要把真相转化为政策。真相与政策之间没有一对一的联系。
When I first started talking to Israelis about this, I expected these histories might have led at least some of them to acknowledge that the Palestinians today have some kind of moral right to be in Israel. None of them saw it this way. Sure, they thought the Palestinians should be treated fairly. That the Palestinians should have their own state. Some thought that there could be reparations. Money. But it didn't lead anybody to question the Israeli's right to keep what they had taken.
当我第一次开始和以色列人谈论这个问题时，我以为这些历史可能会导致他们中至少一部分人承认巴勒斯坦人今天在以色列拥有某种道德权利。他们中没有人这样看。当然，他们认为巴勒斯坦人应该得到公平对待。巴勒斯坦人应该有自己的国家。有些人认为可以有赔偿。钱。但这并没有导致任何人质疑以色列保留其所夺取的东西的权利。
What else can we do? Benny Morris asked me. If you're suggesting Israelis get on a plane and move back to Poland, that's not really an option.
“我们还能做什么？”本尼·莫里斯问我。“如果你是建议以色列人坐上飞机搬回波兰，那真的不是一个选项。”
[MUSIC- "IN THE REAL WORLD" BY ROY ORBISON]
（音乐 - 罗伊·奥比森的《在现实世界中》）
Act Three. Well, there's a military cliche that says something like, generals always re-fight the last war over and over. This next story is an illustration of that principle, even though it is a very different kind of war than the ones you've heard about so far on today's show. Jon Hodgman tells the sorry tale.
第三幕。嗯，有一个军事陈词滥调说，将军们总是反复重打上一场战争。下一个故事就是该原则的例证，尽管它与你们今天节目中听到的那些战争类型完全不同。乔恩·霍奇曼讲述了这个悲伤的故事。
Here is something I'm not quick to admit even to close friends, never mind on the radio. Every day for the past several years, I have been working on a screenplay. This of course, is shameful on its face. But it gets worse, believe me.
这里有一件事我甚至不愿很快向亲密朋友承认，更不用说在广播里了。在过去的几年里，我每天都在写一个电影剧本。这当然在表面上是可耻的。但情况更糟，相信我。
Working on my screenplay has been very hard because the story I'm telling is long and complex and important. It's also difficult because I'm not actually writing anything down. Until recently, I would only think about it, night after night, lying in bed, rewriting my screenplay in my head. And as this process tends to make me sleepy, I've actually not gotten very far.
写剧本一直非常困难，因为我讲述的故事漫长、复杂且重要。这也是困难的，因为我实际上并没有写下任何东西。直到最近，我每天晚上都只是在想，躺在床上，在脑海里重写我的剧本。由于这个过程往往会让我昏昏欲睡，我其实并没走多远。
I began my screenplay on May 19, 1999, a date that may resonate with some of you who may already guess at the other main challenge of my project, the one that lends it the extra measure of sad delusion and ultimate futility that accompanies the writing of any screenplay. And that is that my screenplay has already been written by someone else and it is called Star Wars : Episode I- The Phantom Menace.
我的剧本开始于1999年5月19日，这个日期可能会引起你们中某些人的共鸣，你们可能已经猜到了我项目的另一个主要挑战，那个给它增添了随任何剧本写作而来的那种悲伤的幻觉和最终的徒劳感的挑战。那就是我的剧本已经被别人写过了，它叫《星球大战前传1：幽灵的威胁》。
You will recognize this music, of course. For many people, the opening fanfare embodies just about the sum total of what the Phantom Menace got right. Next, the familiar text crawls up and out into the galaxy. The taxation of outlying trade routes is in dispute we're told. And with this particularly rousing line of exposition, the bewilderment and shock and sadness begins.
你们当然会认出这段音乐。对许多人来说，开场的号角声体现了《幽灵的威胁》做对的总和。接下来，熟悉的文字爬出并进入银河系。我们被告知：“边远贸易航线的征税存在争议。”随着这句特别煽动的博学台词，困惑、震惊和悲伤开始了。
We know this now. But think back to the peculiar exciting year that was 1999. Slightly crazed by the end of the Millennium, we impeached a president for the first time in 131 years. We started paying English majors huge sums of money to create something called content. And in a still disturbing bout of mass hysteria, every American man grew at least one kind of goatee, and we waited for the Phantom Menace.
我们现在知道了。但回想一下1999年那充满奇特兴奋的一年。由于世纪末的轻微疯狂，我们在131年来第一次弹劾了一位总统。我们开始支付给英语专业毕业生巨额资金来创造所谓的“内容”。而在一种依然令人不安的大众歇斯底里中，每个美国男人至少都留了一点山羊胡，我们等待着《幽灵的威胁》。
This was when the internet was at its peak. Still, largely ruled by passion more than commerce. And in many ways, it had found its perfect expression in sites like theforce.net and Starkiller- The Jedi Bendu Script Site, anarchic collaborative communities of information obsessives building a model of what this new Star Wars movie would look like only from rumors, stolen photographs, and leaked script passages. And it somehow felt important that I spend at least an hour a day looking at them. And not just insane.
那时互联网正处于巅峰期。依然主要由激情而不是商业统治。在许多方面，它在TheForce.net和Starkiller-Jedi Bendu剧本网站这样的网站上找到了完美的表达，这些是无政府主义的协作社区，由信息痴迷者组成，仅根据谣言、被盗的照片和泄露的剧本段落，建立起这部新《星球大战》电影将会是什么样子的模型。花费每天至少一小时的时间浏览它们感觉非常重要。而不仅仅是疯狂。
Well, this wasn't always a good thing. When I first downloaded an unofficial audio clip of Jar Jar Binks's quasi-Caribbean Stepin Fetchit whining, I spent a long moment staring doubtfully out the window before quietly deleting the file. But still I had hope.
好吧，这并不总是件好事。当我第一次下载一段非官方的加·加·宾克斯那种类似加勒比海口音的呻吟音频片段时，我盯着窗外怀疑地沉默了很久，然后静静地删除了文件。但无论如何，我还是有希望。
Jump to early May 1999. I saw the Phantom Menace first at a private press screening thanks to a journalist friend of mine who either sympathized with my obsession, or feared what would happen if he did not indulge it. It was probably the first time in history one could go to a new movie, as I did, knowing every scene, every line front to back.
快进到1999年5月初。我先是在一次私人媒体放映会上看了《幽灵的威胁》，多亏了我的一位记者朋友，他要么同情我的痴迷，要么担心如果他不纵容我会发生什么。这可能是历史上第一次有人像我一样，在走进一部新电影时，从头到尾知道每一个场景、每一句台词。
As the lights went down, there was a feeling of joy and imminence in the room. The nation was prosperous and relatively peaceful. I was sitting next to the movie star, Jon Favreau, and Star Wars was coming to fulfill a promise it had made 22 years ago to a generation now coming into its own.
当灯光熄灭时，房间里有一种喜悦和即将来临的感觉。国家繁荣且相对和平。我坐在电影明星乔恩·法夫罗旁边，而《星球大战》正来履行它在22年前对一代人所做的承诺，那一代人现在正在成熟。
When the lights came up though, something had changed. Something had broken and I couldn't put my finger on what it was. The ideas were good, I kept saying as we left the theater and drank, for hours, afterward. There was so much promise there. How could it have all gone so wrong so quickly?
然而当灯光亮起时，有些东西变了。有些东西破裂了，我无法确定是什么。离开影院后，我们喝了几个小时的酒，我一直说：“这些想法是不错的。”那里有那么多的希望。怎么会这么快就全错了？
I started revising that night. First of all, I thought, Anakin Skywalker would have to at least be a teenager. What made George Lucas think we would be OK with the idea of an elderly man taking a nine year old boy away from his mother, Jedi master or no. And that's just creepy.
那天晚上我开始修改。首先，我想，阿纳金·天行者至少应该是个青少年。乔治·卢卡斯怎么会认为我们可以接受一个老男人把一个九岁男孩从他母亲身边带走的想法？无论是不是绝地大师，这都很令人毛骨悚然。
And one of the great pleasures of any Star Wars movie was always the one planet, one climate concept. You had your desert planet, your ice planet, your swamp planet, your cloud planet. Yes, the Phantom Menace had a city planet, but that had already been done with the death star, don't you think? So what is it? What comes after cloud planet?
任何《星球大战》电影的一大乐趣始终是“一星球，一气候”的概念。你有沙漠星球、冰雪星球、沼泽星球、云端星球。是的，《幽灵的威胁》有一个城市星球，但死星已经做过了，你不觉得吗？那么，它是什么？云端星球之后是什么？
Occasionally, I would sneak away from my desk and call my friends. I found a solution to the Jar Jar problem, I would say.
偶尔，我会从书桌前溜走给朋友打电话。我会说：“我找到了解决加·加问题的方案。”
But mainly, I would lie awake at night, alone, and ponder the big questions. What does Darth Sidious want with Naboo in the first place? What were those glowing purple balls of energy the Gungans were always tossing around? And of course, Obi-Wan Kenobi knows R2-D2 from the Phantom Menace , why doesn't he recognize him in Star Wars?
但主要是，我会在晚上独自躺在床上，思考那些大问题。达斯·西迪厄斯到底为什么要针对纳布星？那些冈根人总是扔来扔去的发光紫色能量球是什么？当然，欧比旺·克诺比在《幽灵的威胁》里认识R2-D2，为什么他在《星球大战》里没认出它？
At this point, you will want to know, what is the solution to the Jar Jar problem? I understand, everyone hates Jar Jar. In fact, everything in my screenplay flows from this very simple fix. And that is, replace him with Sebulba.
此时，你们会想知道：加·加问题的解决方案是什么？我明白，每个人都讨厌加·加。事实上，我剧本里的一切都源于这个非常简单的修复。那就是：用塞布尔巴代替他。
OK, Sebulba. You remember the villain in the pod race, the cranky, Joe Camel looking thing in the World War I goggles who walked around on his hands and almost beat Anakin? Switch that guy, Sebulba, with Jar Jar, and what you get is an angrier, more interesting character, who accidentally gets his life saved by Obi-Wan Kenobi during the invasion of Naboo.
好吧，塞布尔巴。记得飞车比赛里的反派吗？那个戴着第一次世界大战护目镜、长相猥琐、像乔·骆驼一样的家伙，用手走路，差点打败阿纳金？用塞布尔巴代替加·加，你得到的是一个更愤怒、更有趣的角色，他在纳布星入侵期间被欧比旺·克诺比无意中救了一命。
Then this hybrid character, let's call him Jarbulba, he now has to follow Obi-Wan around until he has a chance to save Obi-Wan's life. It could take years, Jarbulba would explain, to their mutual dismay. But for now, they're stuck with each other. Obi-Wan, the snobby, young Jedi from the big city, and Jarbulba, the bitter malcontent with the heart of gold. Like Sidney Poitier and Tony Curtis in The Defiant Ones.
然后这个混合角色，我们就叫他加布尔巴，他现在必须跟着欧比旺，直到他有机会救欧比旺一命。这可能需要几年时间，加布尔巴会解释说，让双方都感到沮丧。但目前，他们被困在一起了。欧比旺，来自大城市的傲慢年轻绝地，还有加布尔巴，那个有着金子般心的苦涩不满者。就像《逃狱惊魂》里的西德尼·波蒂埃和托尼·柯蒂斯。
This is a good change for three reasons. One, Jarbulba becomes the cynical Han Solo figure the film so desperately needs. Two, he actually has a reason to go on the rest of the adventure. And three, creatures walking on their hands are cool. But this is only the beginning.
这个改动有三个好处。第一，加布尔巴成为了电影急需的愤世嫉俗的韩·索罗式人物。第二，他确实有理由参加余下的冒险。第三，用手走路的生物很酷。但这只是开始。
In the actual Phantom Menace , the Gungans, Jar Jar's people, have no real purpose in the story. In my screenplay, they do. In my screenplay, it turns out that they're preternaturally sensitive to the Force. And Darth Sidious, the bad guy, needs them like bloodhounds to track down this powerful new concentration in the Force he's been sensing somewhere on the edge of the galaxy. But Jarbulba is a Gungan and he leads our heroes to this concentration first, which turns out to be a teenager on Tatooine, Anakin Skywalker, who uses the Force to win the pod race and is then accused of cheating. Thus having to flee with our heroes who need his skills as a pilot. And so, as act one concludes, Obi-Wan is captain of a crew he can't stand, bound by fate to a strange hand-walking freak, and forced to watch as the dashing and not nine year old, Anakin, captures the heart of the queen that Obi-Wan secretly pines for himself. I will stop talking now.
在真正的《幽灵的威胁》中，冈根人，也就是加·加的族人，在故事中没有任何真正的目的。在我的剧本里，他们有。在我的剧本里，结果证明他们对原力特别敏感。坏蛋达斯·西迪厄斯像猎犬一样需要他们来追踪他在银河系边缘感觉到的这种强大的新原力集中。但加布尔巴是一个冈根人，他首先带领我们的英雄找到了这种集中，结果证明是塔图因上的一个少年，阿纳金·天行者，他利用原力赢得了飞车比赛，随后被指控作弊。因此他不得不和需要他飞行技术的英雄们一起逃亡。于是，当第一幕结束时，欧比旺成了一个他无法忍受的船员的船长，被命运束缚在一个奇怪的、用手走路的怪胎身上，被迫看着风度翩翩、而不是九岁的阿纳金夺取了欧比旺私下里暗恋的女王的心。我不说了。
This is the moment in discussing my screenplay that I begin to feel more and more like someone standing on a cold corner mumbling to himself. And also, this is as far as I've gotten. It's been 31 months. Some 960 days of work and I've only made it to the end of act one. Long after Episode II has come and gone, I'm still trying to get Episode I down. Even though I know I never will. Because even in the midst of my mania, I know I'm trying to repair something more than a script.
这就是讨论我的剧本时，我开始觉得自己越来越像一个站在寒冷的街角对着自己喃喃自语的人的时刻。这也是我目前为止的进展。已经31个月了。工作了大约960天，我只走到了第一幕结束。在《星球大战前传2》早已过去很久之后，我还在试图写完《前传1》。尽管我知道我永远也写不完。因为即使在我的狂躁中，我也知道我试图修复的东西不仅仅是一个剧本。
The Phantom Menace was the beginning of the end. Think about it. It came out in May 1999. Was it a coincidence that the economy then collapsed? That all the promise and light of that time went with it? That my mother became suddenly sick and soon died? That our country was attacked? That we went to war? Well, probably it was a coincidence.
《幽灵的威胁》是终结的开始。想想看。它于1999年5月上映。那时的经济崩溃是个巧合吗？那个时代所有的希望和光明都随之而去是个巧合吗？我母亲突然生病并很快去世是个巧合吗？我们的国家遭到攻击是个巧合吗？我们参加战争是个巧合吗？好吧，这可能确实是个巧合。
But there's a reason I would work on my screenplay while falling asleep. At night, dozing in the hospital while my mother was dying, or when I was awake in bed in October 2001, listening for planes over New York City, when all daylight and distractions were exhausted. Instead of feeling angry or panicked or sad, I could ask myself, what if?
但我写剧本时会睡着是有原因的。晚上，当我母亲临终时在医院里打盹，或者2001年10月我躺在床上清醒时，听着纽约上空的飞机声，当所有的白昼和干扰都耗尽时。我不是感到愤怒、恐慌或悲伤，我可以问自己：“如果……会怎样？”
What if Jar Jar and Sebulba switched places? What if Naboo were a sunken planet, where all that was left of a once great world, a shining civilization, were the tips of mountains, the tallest spires of the cities just poking up above the water's dark surface? Is that what comes after a cloud planet?
如果加·加和塞布尔巴交换位置会怎样？如果纳布星是一个沉没的星球，曾经伟大的世界、闪耀的文明留下的只有山峰的尖端，城市的最高尖塔就在水黑暗的表面上露出一点点会怎样？那是云端星球之后的东西吗？
It's an odd compulsion to tell a story correctly. We feel it every time we tell a joke or interrupt our spouse in the middle of the one about the time we drunkenly broke into the London Zoo. Wait, go back, you say. Wait, go back and start over.
这是一种奇怪的、要正确讲述一个故事的强迫症。我们每次讲笑话或在配偶讲起我们醉酒闯入伦敦动物园的那次经历时打断他们，都会有这种感觉。“等一下，回去，”你会说。“等一下，回去重新开始。”
And maybe this is not really borne of a desire to get the beginning right, but to avoid ever having to come to the end. I know it's futile to go on with my screenplay. And to tell the truth, it isn't offering me the same kind of comfort that it used to. The story will end the way it ends. All I really needed was to get this far. As Obi-Wan and Jarbulba, Anakin and the queen fly off in the desert planet, the point where the adventure is just starting, with everything still promised and unknown. Because beginnings are really the only happy endings.
也许这并非真正源于想要把开头写好的愿望，而是为了避免不得不迎来结尾。我知道继续写我的剧本是徒劳的。说实话，它并没有给我提供像以前那样的安慰。故事会按照它该有的方式结束。我真正需要的就是走这么远。当欧比旺和加布尔巴、阿纳金和女王飞离沙漠星球时，冒险才刚刚开始，一切依然充满希望且未知。因为开始才是唯一快乐的结局。
John Hodgman in New York City.
纽约市的乔恩·霍奇曼。
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Dave Kestenbaum, and Starlee Kine. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Jane Golombisky, and Mr. Jorge Just in a special cameo.
嗯，我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我本人制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格、温迪·多尔、戴夫·凯斯滕鲍姆和斯塔莉·基恩。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴克曼、简·戈隆比斯基和豪尔赫·贾斯特先生在片中客串了特别出演。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢名单）
BZ Goldberg who you heard in our Israel story is one of the creators of a great film about Israeli and Palestinian kids. If you want to know more about that visit promisesproject.org.
你在我们的以色列故事中听到的BZ·戈德堡是一位关于以色列和巴勒斯坦孩子伟大电影的创作者之一。如果你想了解更多，请访问promisesproject.org。
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago or visit our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org.
如果你想购买本节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ或访问我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由美国公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助单位名单）
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says it is not easy wearing a Darth Vader costume everywhere.
WBEZ管理监督托雷·马拉蒂亚，他说在任何地方都穿着达斯·维达的服装并不容易。
I piss my pants. My heart rate climbs. My breathing becomes shallow in the mask.
我尿裤子了。我的心跳加速。在面具里我的呼吸变得急促。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，美国公共广播国际公司。